Straight Outta Compton is directed by F
gary Gray and is about the formation of
the group NWA in the late 80s to early
90s their impact on the music scene and
everything that has happened since as a
repercussion of their artistry and all
the hardships that came along with the
lifestyle they were leading as well as
all the difficulties they had to try to
make themselves actually be considered
legitimate artists and the main three
members this movie mostly focuses on is
Ice Cube dr. Dre and eazy-e now if you
don't know who these people are they are
extremely influential in their field I
grew up in this time period I grew up in
Akron Ohio and I would walk to school
and a lot of times I'd see people with
boom boxes just walking around with
their shoulders those D cell batteries
powering those things and blasting this
type of music so there was definitely
some nostalgia because I remember
hearing those songs as a kid tons of
people in my school would sing that even
though we weren't really allowed and
I've always had a strange fascination
with icecube
don't know why that is he started such
box-office hits as anaconda xxx State of
the Union and barbershop and I might
just have one of those
the first hour this movie was extremely
entertaining in really well paced you'd
see Ice Cube sitting on a bus going to
and from school writing notes about
lyrics that he wants to have in a song
you felt the desire there you see dr.
Dre practicing spinning on his table and
you just felt this intense passion they
had for their art and that's one of the
reasons why I didn't like the last half
of the movie as much because as the band
gets so bogged down in the money aspect
of it all the movie gets more dramatic
it gets more personal but you lose that
passion in their eyes in their voice you
don't feel that heat they have for the
music and so some of the energy in the
movie does dwindle but as an overall
film I had a great time a straight out
of Compton despite the fact that last
half I didn't think was as good as the
first half it was still a consistently
entertaining movie and one in which I
was always curious to see where these
characters were going to go Ice Cube is
played by the real-life ice cubes son
and he does a great job in the movie he
obviously looks exactly like him he
really surprised me cuz I wasn't
entirely sure how that was going to go
like imagine playing your dad at a movie
that'd be fucking weird but he did a
great job in fact the entire cast did a
really good job Paul Giamatti who I had
no idea was in this movie was also very
good as their band manager and he has
some secrets of his own it definitely
glosses over and sometimes entirely
skips real-life events that you know
took place with some of these people and
I can see why because Ice Cube and dr.
Dre are both producers behind this movie
and I can kind of see them being like
hey can you not put that one thing that
happened because it would make us look
really bad it would've been nice to just
have a little more honesty in the story
but it doesn't change the fact that the
movie as a whole really works it's
really entertaining it's well acted the
music and the soundtrack is great
there's also a timeliness to this movie
that is unfortunately extremely apparent
when you watch it knowing some of the
things going on in today's news Straight
Outta Compton is a very fun biopic it
has a great soundtrack good performances
and despite the fact that the last half
doesn't really have the same brisk
energy as the first half it's still a
very well-made film and I think it's one
of F gary Gray is best I'm gonna give
straight out of Compton of B+
so guys what are your thoughts in this
movie what other biopics would you like
to see fingers crossed for MC Hammer or
vanilla ice I'm kidding
by the way guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes